لم يصمت الرصاص في السودان في هدن تم
الاتفاق عليها ما دفع الدول للبدء بعمليات
اجلاء رعاياها تحت النار تصدرت السعوديه
الدول التي اجلت رعاياها ورعايه دول اخرى
باول عمليه اجلاء لمدنيين حيث نقلت القوات
البحريه السعوديه اكثر من 150 شخصا من
السعوديين ورعاي دول اخرى من بورسودان الى
جده عبر البحر الاحمر
ووسطى تبادل الجيش وقوات حملت الاتهامات
بشان اطلاق النار اثناء عمليه اجلاء رعايه
فرنسيين كان احدها هؤلاء الرعايه قد اصيب
ولفتت الخارجيه الفرنسيه الى ان اجلاء
رعياها يشمل ايضا مواطنين اوروبيين ودول
حليفه بدورها بدات بريطانيا والمانيا
واسبانيا في اجلاء رعاياها كما ارسلت
اليونان طائرات وقوات خاصه الى مصر
استعدادا لاجلاء 120 يونانيا وقبرصيا من
الخر كذلك فعلت هولندا بارسال طائرتين
تابعتين للسلاح الجو وطائره مدنيه الى
الاردن استباقا لمهمه انقاذ محتمله فيما
اوفدت ايطاليا طائرات عسكريه الى دوله
جيبوتي استعدادا لاجلاء 140 من رعاياها في
السودان كما حدث كل من الاردن ولبنان
حدوات الك الدول وارسلت طائرات تقل رعياها
بالاضافه الى رعايه عرب واجانب كما اعلن
الاردن على لسان جيشه فيما بدا الرئيس
الامريكي مرتاحا لاجلاء 70 شخصا هم موظفوا
سفره الامريكيه في الخرطوم الى اثيوبيا
وبخلاف الرعب الذي يحرم حول عمليات
الاجلاء المهدده باشتعال القتال في اي وقت
فهناك تعقيدات اخرى منها شلل المطار
الرئيسي اضافه الى ايقاف تشغيل المطارات
الاخرى في انحاء السودان حنان المصري
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات